[Musique]
j'aimerais enfin on a on a dit dans son
émission qu'on faisait pas de langue de
bois alors excusez-moi meilleur mois
depuis le début de l'émission tu
horrifié les autres monsieur bédié qui
nous promet qu'il va tenir ses promesses
on est très content un bon il souffre
beaucoup monsieur mélenchon notamment un
des critiques qui sont faites aux
politiques et pourtant qu'est ce que
vous les méritez un parce que qui a
contribué à faire croire aux français
que l'intégralité des hommes politiques
étaient malhonnêtes c'est vous et c'est
vous parce que vous parce que parce que
mais oui bien sûr marty mais qui à
l'échelle la caisse claire t l'udf et le
pc vous voulez que je vous rappelle à
cet homme d'affaires parce que monsieur
alpha ne le fera plus il a oublié lui
les affaires il a oublié la lutte contre
la corruption puisqu'il a voté pour le
premier de la gamme france alors la
langue de bois et bien c'est son la
langue de bois vous avez construit à la
dénonciation
la démocratie ce n'est pas fini on
attendait un peu les construire la
démocratie je me rendais l'arrêt sur mon
papa il est qui va venir vous parler de
la démocratie représentative par boîte
de lait dont par douala dont marine le
pen ce monsieur marine le pen
marine le pen pardon je le dis à tous
pour easy a sombré depuis 15 ans mais
pour éviter en tout cas que ce débat
puisse ressembler à certains autres qui
ont été très critiqués je vous demande
un peu de 10 lte et houdinois ont levé
le doigt qui part dieu qui m'insultent
alors exactement vous assumerez d'imagés
attire salembrais le jeu je le dis à
vous comme aux autres un peu de calme
salut j'ai vraiment nous avons du temps
mais c'est pas contre nous et je dis ça
voilà en tout cas je rien n'aura mais
vous parlez aux autres et non mais vous
êtes enceinte c'est aussi pour le public
et les citoyens pour ne pas applaudir
pour tout le monde se respecte
[Musique]